SALMAN KHAN: This is Sal again.
I'm here at Stanford Medical
School with Doctor Abraham
Verghese and what are
we going to talk about?
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
We're going to talk
about the ritual of the
physical exam, the bedside exam.
SALMAN KHAN: The physical
exam, the ritual--
why do you call it a ritual?
That's interesting that
you call it a ritual.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: Yeah,
I think the lesson
I've learned from hanging around
with my anthropology colleagues
here at Stanford is that rituals
are all about transformation.
A ritual signals the
crossing of a threshold.
You baptize to signal the
crossing of a threshold,
we marry to signal our departure
from a life of solitude,
loneliness, and misery
to one of eternal bliss.
SALMAN KHAN: Yes.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
So our lives are
full of-- You shouldn't
be laughing Sal.
SALMAN KHAN: No.
It resonates so
strongly with me.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: So
crossing a threshold is
why we have a ritual.
And I would say that the
act of one individual
coming to another, and telling
them things they wouldn't tell
their rabbi or their preacher,
and then incredibly disrobing
and allowing touch, I
would say that that signals
a ritual of
incredible importance.
And the fact that
we, in the postmodern
sort of medical world,
have stopped seeing it
that way and just see it as
another data gathering tool may
work for us, but I don't think
it works for the patient.
And I think that a major
disconnect between us
and our patients is our
failure to see what they see,
which is a profound ritual in
which they're highly invested.
And we then come and just
stick our stethoscope
on top of the shirt, or don't
examine them thoroughly,
we are sort of short
changing ourselves
of an important ritual.
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah, and
I'll feel short changed.
I'm kidding.
Sorry.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: But
I'd love to list for you,
if I may, those aspects of
what makes this a ritual.
So if you look at
it, first of all
there's always a
specialized space.
You don't examine a patient
out in the corridor.
It's always a special room, a
ceremonial room if you will.
Mysterious looking objects on
the walls, a very specialized
bed that you sit on.
These are all signals
that this is a virtual.
Then when the physician
walks in the physician
often is wearing
a ceremonial garb,
which happens to
be a white coat.
SALMAN KHAN: Fascinating.
This is interesting just from an
anthropological point of view.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: The physician
is wearing ceremonial garment.
The patient is also
instructed to disrobe
and gets a patient garment.
SALMAN KHAN: Which
seems specially designed
to put patients in a
position of weakness.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: I know.
It's quite unfortunate.
We should be rethinking
the [INAUDIBLE] garments
[? major. ?]
And then the physician then
begins a systematic exam,
which at some level is
mysterious to the patient.
It's not always
clear to the patient
why the physician is
thumping on their chest
or why the physician is
saying take a deep breath,
or cross your arms, or stand
on tiptoe, or take your hand
and touch your nose rapidly.
So there's mysterious and
ritualistic aspects to it.
And very often the
physician is using
terms that are somewhat
Latinate and arcane, and utterly
mysterious to the patient such
as fremitus, and percussion.
SALMAN KHAN: What
does fremitus mean?
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: Fremitus means
you ask the patient to say 99,
and you listen, you put
your hand on their chest.
You pick up the vibration,
and if they have consolidation
or collapse the
fremitus is not what
it should be compared
to the other side.
SALMAN KHAN: The fremitus,
so was it the sound or the--
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: It's
more like the vibration.
Sound being transmitted
through and being picked up
by your hand.
SALMAN KHAN: Interesting.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
So the thing that's
most interesting to
me about the ritual
is that the person
coming in might
be a policeman, a
teacher, an entrepreneur,
but in the process of
putting on that gown,
and sitting on that
ceremonial chair,
they have sort of been
stripped of all that identity,
and they are taking on the
identity of being the patient.
But conversely, I think there's
something very important that
happens, which is that just
before this the patient has
been vocalizing all their
symptoms and their complaints,
and at that point the physician
could order ten tests,
and go and look at
images, but there's
something about the
physician then laying
hands on the patient,
that sort of gives weight
to what the patient
just talked about.
You talk about
your belly hurting,
and then this individual
carefully examines your belly.
It's sort of
validating your soma.
Your body is being
validated in this ritual.
And then when you
finally have the tests
all sent off they become sort
of-- what follows intuitively
on the ritual of first having
it validated on your body.
One of the things that
I bemoan sometimes
is that at times the
patient in the bed,
I feel, in hospitals
around America,
has almost become an icon
for the real patient who's
in the computer.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
It's just something
to interface with
to get to that data
structure in the computer.
It's interesting.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
I've coined a term
for that entity in the computer.
It's the iPatient.
When the iPatient is getting
fabulous care the real patient
I think has a need to feel
their complaints validated.
To feel it validated
on their soma,
and to engage in a ritual for
which there's a transformation.
And you might well ask me,
what is the transformation
that takes place in this ritual?
And, I think the
transformation is
the sense of the patient
has delivered the story,
the physician in the
process of the ritual
has validated that
they've heard the story
and tried to locate
it on the soma,
and the transformation
is really the ceiling
of the patient
physician relationship.
And so I think what
has happened Sal,
unfortunately, is
that because we
have so much technology we've
become very sloppy in the way
we examine patients.
I think that we should be a
hundredfold better at examining
people given that we
have real-time feedback
with echocardiograms,
angiograms, and all that.
Instead of which, I
think people have never
been less certain of
their bed side skills.
SALMAN KHAN: What
about this phenomenon,
just talking to physicians
I know in my own family,
that there's so
much time pressure.
They have to see so many
patients, one every 15 minutes,
and all of this, and they
wish they could do this,
but they'll say that I have
so many other things to worry
about, and the
paperwork, and all that.
Is it realistic?
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: No, I think
that's a very real concern.
But I think if you
can do this well.
And our goal at Stanford
is to teach our students
to do it very well.
You actually save time.
Because if you do a quick
exam and you find that they're
tender in a certain spot you
can order the test that sources
just that out,
rather than, which
I think is much more common,
which is I don't really
know what's going on,
I'll tick off every box,
and maybe something will
fall out of the sky.
So I think a directed exam,
not only fulfills the ritual,
but if you're any good
at it, it actually
allows you to ask better
questions of a test you order
and minimize the patient's
exposure to radiation.
And I think the trouble
is we get all these tests,
and we get back
results we don't know
what to do with, we stumble onto
what we call incidentalomas.
Have you heard that term?
SALMAN KHAN: Incidentaloma.
Well, I have heard that VIP's
often get worse medical care
because they do
everything for them.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
Yeah, exactly and they
wind up with finding things
they don't know what to do.
SALMAN KHAN: Exactly yeah
over diagnosing things.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: But to
come back to a ritual,
I think we at Stanford
are very proud to feel
that, as much as we
represent this great bastion
of technology and
advancement, we also celebrate
the fundamental ritual aspects
of the patient physician
relationship, which
is best symbolized
in the physical exam.
SALMAN KHAN: I think this
is why a lot of physicians
originally want to
enter the field.
It sometimes gets lost, but this
is why they wanted to do it.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
And you're right.
I think they often
get disappointed
when they learn to do this
and arrive on the wards
and find that no one's
carrying a stethoscope,
and no one's carrying-- I mean
they carry the stethoscope.
I think it's like
a mating symbol.
SALMAN KHAN: No you gotta
carry one to look legitimate.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: But they
don't carry the knee hammer,
and they don't carry
all the other tools.
SALMAN KHAN: I once visited
my wife at the doctor
and I wore her coat,
and I felt very good.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: Did you
drape your stethoscope
around the neck too?
SALMAN KHAN: Oh I did.
Yeah, I looked
very authoritative.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE: That's a
great signal that you arrived.
So I think that we
have so much to learn
from our anthropology colleagues
about the importance of ritual.
I think sometimes we
operate as though medicine
is all about reason, but it's
really reason, ritual, emotion.
They all tie in together.
This is art and science.
SALMAN KHAN: No.
This is fascinating.
I'm going to reflect
on some of the rituals
I do now to see if they are.
Very cool.
Well, thank you for this.
ABRAHAM VERGHESE:
Thank you so much.